OK, we are continuing to learn about who the
individuals involved in the January 6th Trump riot
are and who they were and what areas of society
and industry they came from. Now, I already told
you it was either last week or maybe the week
before that members of the military, current and
former, were dramatically overrepresented among
the Trump rioters. On January six, something like
14 percent of those arrested were either
former or current members of the military.
That's very concerning. And we now have another
individual story, 14 percent is a general number.
We now have an individual story that's even
more horrifying, according to TIME, a man who
authorities say is a leader of the far right Oath
Keepers militia group and helped to organize other
extremists in their participation in the January
6th Trump riots. No one held a top secret security
clearance for decades, and No. Two previously
worked for the FBI, according to his own attorney.
Now, you might be wondering, why is this guy,
his own attorney, saying these things? It it
raises more concerns. It should make us horrified
that that was the position this guy held. Well,
his attorney is raising these issues to justify
that he should be out on bail and that he's
super trustworthy. And you don't have to. Worry
about him. The man's name is Thomas Cauldwell,
authorities believe that he has a leadership role
in this extremist group called the Oath Keepers.
He was FBI section chief between 2009 and 2010.
This is not any FBI person would be a real red
flag in terms of their participation. But this was
not a nobody to the extent that there are nobody
in the FBI. This was a section chief from 2009
to 2010. Previously, he was in the Navy. Again,
we talked about the overrepresentation of
members of the military among the Trump riders.
And his lawyer, Thomas Afshan, wrote in a
motion saying, listen, look at this guy's creds.
You can safely release him as he awaits trial
because he was in the Navy and
he was FBI section chief. And
the reason why you can trust him is he had this
top secret security clearance and he worked for
the FBI and he had a consulting firm that did work
for the U.S. government. This guy is trustworthy.
And, of course, as many of us learned more and
more about the individuals involved in the January
6th riot, we are horrified. We are horrified
about wow. I mean, listen, people can change
in 11 years, right? This guy was FBI section chief
from 2009 to 2010. In twenty twenty one, he finds
himself participating in the Trump riot. Many
of us would logically be led to ask, did the FBI
miss signs about this guy back in 2009? And the
counterargument will be, well, no, the FBI could
have done its job at vetting in 2009. There really
might have been nothing there then. And something
happened since then that ended up radicalizing
this guy to the point where he's part of the
Oath Keepers, this right wing militia group, and
he's participating in the January 6th riots. But
we all should be asking who else is in there now?
Who's in the military now? Who's in the FBI now
that has the same ideas, the same ideology, the
same allegiances for lack of a better term is this
guy and we just don't know about that yet. That is
a very, very concerning element of this. And the
truth is, we should be horrified that these are
the individuals that not just participated, but
allegedly were organizers of the Trump riot. This
is essentially a terrorist. This is someone who
organized others to attempt a violent insurrection
because they didn't like the results of a
democratically held election. There's really
no other way to define what these folks are.
And the other kind of a few people wrote to me
and they said, you know, it's interesting that
this guy, Cauldwell, is now he's he's disabled
legally. He is on disability and he's received
he's on the government dole, so to speak. And
pointing out people were pointing out two things.
One is less interesting to me. Some folks wrote
to me and said, David, this guy clearly is not
disabled because he was able to participate in the
riots. I think that that's the wrong angle to go
at. I think it starts to get into these sometimes
prejudicial or discriminatory things about what is
a disabled person look like. And I don't like
that. I'm not going to go in that direction.
The part that is more interesting from a political
standpoint is that a lot of anti-government
extremists. Are sometimes completely dependent on
the government. And that reminds me of, you know,
keep the government out of my Medicare sort of
stuff, where do people not understand where their
benefits are coming from or do they not
care? Or are they blinded by ideology?
Is it some combination of all of all of
the above? That's more interesting to me,
evaluating whether someone is or isn't truly
disabled based on whether they're at the riot.
I'm not going to get involved in that. But the
numbers continue to be concerning. 14 percent of
those arrested, former or current military. We
now are learning more about individuals who were
relatively high ranking folks within agencies up
to and including the FBI. This should horrify all
of us. We know that the military has been looking
at white supremacy within its ranks for some time.
But what is the FBI doing? What is
the CIA doing? How many of these folks
are in there within the system? And what does that
mean going forward? When we think about federal
responses to events like this, which hopefully
will be very infrequent, but but history tells us
it is bound to happen again at some point,
and how prepared will we actually be?
Let me know your thoughts. You
can find me on Twitter at David
Pakman will be back. And much to discuss today.